I are Mikes my phonetics guide com4 why
looking at the facial animation in
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles bringing
cartoon characters to a live-action
setting has its problems especially when
your stars are talking Turtles in the
first of what looks like a brand new
franchise ILM was given the role of
rama's wisecracking hard fighting and
fast talking turtles to the screen and
actually it was ILM who suggested one of
the film's funniest scenes three name of
the show is the premise for the humor
the sheer absurdity as a characters
namely that their Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles so it was in fact visual effects
supervisor Pablo Hellman who actually
decided to base these characters as much
as possible on the real actors and in so
doing he significantly overhauled the
face capture pipeline at ILM it was a
great opportunity for us to have four
performers on set and to develop a
technology that will allow us to give
the director a chance to direct capture
those performances we target those
performances onto a digital asset and
then bring in an animator to reinterpret
that performance and bring all the
artistry into the performance the new
system has the human actors being
recorded for detailed motion capture and
also now being filled with a pair of
stereo high-resolution face cameras
compared to the old single camera helmet
mount or in fact in the case violence
pirates of the carribean just witness
cameras but the motion capture system
needs to feed a very animator friendly
rig actually the first point cloud from
the motion capture feeds a rig that's
designed around a digital version of the
actual actor and does then retarget it
to a rig for their individual character
the second stage of retargeting to a
turtle face has to accommodate the
significantly different head structure
the turtles mouths for example are much
bigger their nose is significantly less
prominent but wider and their eyes are
higher in the head but smaller they
break the standard golden ratio triangle
which nearly all human faces have from
the nose to the corners of the mouth
thus the rig could only be partly driven
by the facial mocap facespace
interestingly one of the film's simpler
and funniest scenes shows us all very
clearly and it was actually never
scripted to be in the film
Pablo Hellman just noticed the actors
goofing off between takes and then he
suggested that it become a scene in the
film I had recorded something with my
iPhone on the first week of New York in
top of the roof in which the actors were
just dancing around Megan Fox and they
were just being goofy it was so much fun
together and they had so much chemistry
and they were so excited about being the
Turtles while the team tried to be
faithful to the performer the data can't
fit skull the skull the turtles were
made to have the same muscles as humans
to help but just remapping the data from
the different shaped heads would mean
that the actors expressions would
perhaps become unclear or or be misread
a smile would no longer be read as a
smile in the end it came down to ILM
terrifically talented animators to make
sure that the acting choices of say Noah
Fisher translated to what we see on
screen as Michelangelo well don't forget
to subscribe for more behind the scenes
action I'm Mike Seymour for wide
you